[Music]
so I would like to start by telling you
the story of a woman who died in Nevada
in last August her death brought the
discussion of antibiotics resistance to
the news once again basically she
traveled to India and while she was
there she broke her right leg and then
when she returned to the US she went to
the hospital to treat her like injury
and while she was doing some exams the
doctors discovered she was of an
infection in her leg and hip bones but
the doctors also determined that no
amount of antibiotics would be enough to
save her life because she was infected
with motor resistant bacteria that were
immune to all the drugs they had so
there was nothing they could do to help
her I would love to tell you this is an
unusual case or an exception that that
antibiotics can treat the bacterial
infections we have today but actually
that's no longer true do you have any
idea of how many people die each year
due to this kind of infection 700,000
more or less that might not seem so much
when compared to the 6.4 million deaths
caused by stroke or even the eighth
point 76 million deaths caused by heart
disease however the predictions show
that by 2050 resistant bacteria will
kill around 10 million people a year if
nothing is done to stop them which means
that stories like the one I told you
will become more common than stories of
people dying of stroke heart disease or
cancer if we think that around 60
million people died in World War two
during the six years the war lasted it
will be the same number of deaths per
year as World War two that means the
same number of casualties of our
history's deadliest conflict we thought
antibiotics would forever protect us
from bacteria right but the current
situation is showing us
that's wrong so as I told you we're
facing a war against bacteria but who
are the characters in this war so we can
compare the harmful bacteria to an enemy
army our immune cells to the soldiers of
our army and antibiotics to the weapons
of our army in this crazy battle if you
are in an actual war do you think it is
clever to keep constantly attacking your
enemy using the same weapons and
strategies no right of course not
because you make it easier for your
opponents to the feature they can
analyze your attack methods build up
defenses and then attack you back with
the advantages on their side and now you
might be thinking but that's quite
predictable isn't it we can have been so
naive to do that and the answer is yes
we were bacteria have been doing this
analysis for more than 70 years
eventually discovering the resistance
genes which is the way they found to
protect themselves from our antibiotics
and this is how this happens
imagine you have a person that it's with
an infection in their guts and there's
the back the bacterial colony that it's
making this infection and in this colony
one bacterium is resistant to
antibiotics effects then the person
takes the antibiotics and as they get in
contact with the colony the regular
bacteria start to die but the resistant
one doesn't and now it finds itself if
the fault with the whole space and all
the nutrients for itself and then it
starts to grow and grow and grow and in
the end we have another colony of now
resistant bacteria so as you can see
antibiotics sometimes don't solve our
problem because they don't kill the
bacteria they instead select the
resistant worms and this is how
antibiotics excessive use becomes a
problem because the more we use them the
more we increase the chances of ending
up selecting resistant bacteria and to
make matters worse
resistant bacteria can share they're
resistant genes which is that circular
DNA there with other bacteria that were
previously not resistant allowing not
only new bacteria to become resistant
but also to become resistant to other
types of drugs because one resistant
gene is effective against one kind of
antibiotic and they do this process in a
very simple way much like a friend that
comes close to you you give it up you
give him or her a present a gift and
then they leave that's it so there you
have one bacteria that has a resistant
gene and under the doesn't so they get
very close together they shared their
inner parts the resistant bacteria makes
a copy of that gene gives it to the
other and then they split and now Bofur
resistant and since bacteria have been
doing this process since 1945 when the
first resistant bacteria were found
today there are certain kinds of
bacteria that are immune to almost all
or even all antibiotics we have because
they have found all the ingredients for
this global resistant rasa resistance
recipe which means there's no cure for
them we use antibiotics to make animals
get fat faster so we can slay them and
sell their meat to protect plants from
agricultural plagues people
self-medicate in many many countries and
even doctors sometimes make mistakes and
prescribe antibiotics for diseases they
can treat we can't do these things
anymore in the pace who have been doing
in the last years if we still want
antibiotics protection Alexander Fleming
received his Nobel award for discovering
penicillin the first antibiotic he
warned us about the consequences of
using antibiotics excessively an advice
that was ignored by the pharmaceutical
industry according to him the
thoughtless person playing with
penicillin treatment is morally
responsible for the death of a man who
succumbs to penicillin resistant
organism there is another problem which
is the consequences of these drugs in
our bodies so antibiotics are drugs that
are made to kill bacteria making no
distinction between the bacteria that
are harmful or helpful to us
our bodies are great environment for
bacteria believe it or not your body has
ten times more bacteria cells than human
cells there are certain bacteria that
live in our guts that are so important
to us that we could not live without
them they can be compared to the people
in this microscopic war helping us the
nation and our immune selves the
soldiers to face this war they helped us
in digestion to absorb essential
nutrients they fight harmful
microorganisms and they also help us
recover from illness because they
stimulate our immune system to produce
immune cells or more soldiers when we
take antibiotics we are removing part of
this natural defences which makes us
feel even weaker and although there are
ways to make up for the damage caused by
antibiotics and our gut flora few people
take the time to make the proper
supplementation of probiotics probiotics
or these helpful bacteria by eating
cheese yogurt or probiotic capsules
therefore we need to find new weapons
and strategies to turn the tide in this
war and so the possible solutions are
the develop of new drugs not only new
antibiotics new and different
antibiotics but that new vaccines as
well improving sanitation conditions
cutting off the use of antibiotics in
livestock and agriculture and start
using antibiotics wisely and consciously
aware of the consequences they can cause
to to us and the last one and most
important of all make other people aware
as well as we can't just go to a lab and
create a new drug to solve the problem
we must help the way we can washing our
hands wearing warm coats during the
winter eating fruits and vegetables
basically everything our mothers have
told us to do so many times in order to
prevent illness it's very important to
share this information make people aware
explain why we should stop using
antibiotics excessively antibiotics are
such a valuable tool and we rely on them
for so many things we can't just lose
them because of our irresponsibility the
future is in our hands now we can either
hold it or let it fall between our
fingers let's make the right choice
thank you
[Applause]